So we'll start off by talking about blueprint usage and blueprints are used to drive level
based events.
So they control internally scripted behaviors for in game actors and you can even control
complex animations for game characters.
So the blueprint system, you'll see these windows across many different editors, whether
or even Niagara audio blueprints can be used to be the code driven driving block behind
different real time interactions.
So what are blueprints?
So in their basic form blueprints are visual scripts that use to add new functionality
to your game by connecting the nodes, events and functions, which is what you see in the
images here with wires.
So you can create some kind of intended interactive outcome.
So you'll see that we have events which are setting these red nodes on the right hand
side and then you'll see some kind of function based gameplay.
So the functions are the blue node on the top right hand corner, for example, connected
to some kind of variable data.
So you'll see these wires connecting and it's almost like a chain of events.
You can follow the logic from left to right and get the intended outcome of what you want
your blueprint to be.
So we'll dive into the editor later in this course, but just to give you a bit of an overview
of the interface you may expect to see inside of Unreal.
So when we open our blueprint editor, which you can do by clicking the node graph on the
top of your editor and just go to open level blueprint, you can see that.
But just to dig into a bit more detail here, so we have the text menus on the top, which
you'd expect to see across all of Unreal Engine.
But the bar that you'll be using a lot is on this number two section here.
So you have compile, which every time you're editing a blueprint or changing the functionality,
you want to make sure you compile and save and it just keeps the iteration going.
You can ensure that although the code is working correctly and of course saving your
work at frequent stages because especially when you're first getting familiar with blueprints
and maybe you connect some nodes that may end up crashing or failing, you just want
to keep that information safe so that if the editor does shut for whatever reason, you've
not lost any work.
We can browse content and find content and change settings slightly more complex.
A good thing to point out on the right hand side here is you can debug information as
well.
So when we get into the workshop, we can show you how to do that, but you'll very commonly
be using the compile and save a lot in this section.
Number three is where your components live.
So a blueprint, say it houses multiple components.
So say you had a vehicle in your production and you wanted to add some headlights to that
vehicle.
So you'd add maybe two spotlights to that vehicle.
Now the spotlights would be in this component list.
So not only would the vehicle be there as a static mesh, the two headlights would then
be there and you can see that any extra elements you're adding to that vehicle are all components.
So say you added a separate door mesh or some kind of information inside the vehicle like
some boxes or anything like this.
These would all be components within this blueprint.
Then you've got number four, which is your blueprint panel.
So this is where all of your functions live.
It's where all the inputs.
So we've got both an event begin play, which fires at the very start of the game.
And again, I'm just giving an example here.
We'll get into much more detail later on, but this fires at the start of the game and
you can see the F key being pressed on the keyboard.
So we can see event begin play on the left hand side and F as they're both inputs that
fire during runtime.
You've got your functions that live here and your construction script, which we'll be going
into again in this course.
And then this is where your variables live.
So you can create different variables, booleans, integers, floats, whatever kind of variables
you need to drive some kind of gameplay conditions.
Event dispatchers also live here and event dispatchers help with blueprint communication.
It's almost like a message that gets sent out to another blueprint, which we will of
course dig into.
Number five is where all the main action is happening.
This is where you're connecting your wires and your nodes to get the desired outcome.
A few important things to point out here.
Viewport will go to the visual view of what the blueprint is.
So say going back to this vehicle example from your components on the left hand side,
if you go to viewport, you can then view that vehicle.
The construction script is something that fires every time you compile the blueprint.
So if you want any kind of custom editor functionality or some default property setting, the construction
script is a great way to do that.
The event graph will always be at runtime.
So whenever you've got your main bit of the interactive experience that you're creating,
that's where all of the blueprint will live.
And you'll see that we have almost like functional blueprints and then an arrow saying event
graph.
Each you can create sub layers and sub layers of blueprints.
So you can almost nest blueprints within other blueprints.
So you may even see multiple graphs appear in here as well.
And then also you can open up your function, which is a print text function.
So you can see this function over here, which says print text.
And that also lives up there.
So number six, this is where we can change all the details of the content that we've
created.
So in this example, we've created a new Boolean value down on the bottom left here.
And then by selecting this Boolean value, you'll see that it's got a great naming convention
new var underscore one.
But then you can edit new var underscore zero, sorry, no, one here.
So you can see that the variable types of Boolean, you can change a bunch of properties
here, which again, we'll be digging into in more detail throughout this course.
But that's just to give you a basic overview of the editor.